[Music]
so you consider yourself a copy you're
obsessed with where it's sourced oh it's
roasted and a million ways you can throw
it while these guys are the supreme
coffee geeks fave help sequence the
genome of a coffee plant and made the
data public that's huge for breeders and
for consumers like you and me
specifically the scientists looked at
the genes of the geisha variety of
coffee plant which is renowned for its
complex flavors and consequent
astounding price tag like over $300 for
a half pound so to sequence a genome we
basically start with collecting leaves
we we grind those leaves up and we use
some detergents and a few chemicals like
ethanol and the key is to extract the
DNA is intact as possible so this is the
machine that does the actual sequencing
and these are called smart cells in each
of these there are 150,000 individual
cells into which DNA will drop the
Machine picks up those molecules and
starts sequencing them so you can see
here that these are all the molecules in
one of these cells and you get the red
and yellow and green the corresponds to
the letters of the DNA by doing this
over and over and over the Machine
slowly built the genome what scientists
end up with is unprecedented insight
into how a coffee plant is built the
genome is really the blueprint or the
base for the what the genes are doing
and trying to understand why is coffee
good and why some coffee tastes better
than other coffee when some coffee might
grow well this is California and Mexico
and the plant breeders can use that
information to rapidly combine important
traits that means we're about to enter a
Renaissance of coffee think new
varieties grown in more places with
better resistance to disease
I'll do to that though I probably should
have mentioned I'm more of a tea man
well